la banque zhenya dory contrôle aujourd'hui
presque tout le territoire du pays
y compris la capitale, ce sont des réalités et c'est de
ces réalités doivent progresser en développant non
permettant l'effondrement inconditionnel de l'Afghanistan
les États doivent arrêter
politique irresponsable d'imposer
de dehors
les valeurs et les aspirations de quelqu'un d'autre
construire la démocratie dans d'autres pays
les habitudes des autres, sans ignorer
historiques non nationaux et
caractéristiques religieuses
ignorant complètement les traditions
d'autres nations vivent
nous connaissons l'afghanistan, nous connaissons bien
s'est assuré du fonctionnement de ce pays
et comment contre-productif d'essayer
utilisé pour lui imposer des formes inhabituelles
administration publique et
la vie publique telle
expériences sociales et politiques
n'ont jamais réussi et
conduire qu'à la destruction d'États avant
gradations politiques et sociales
systèmes